[Music]
okay so we're back at it again we're at
AMC we just saw one called and it was
just called Robin Hood
right which is kind of like it's Robin
Hood placed in I guess kind of a future
a possible future kind of like into the
Badlands where it's a mixture of the
past and the future which is kind of the
way they were originally gonna do the
first Conan but I don't know I kind of
got a vibe almost like the Baz Luhrmann
Romeo and Juliet where it was like it
was obviously set in the Middle Ages
because it was you know during the
Crusades but then like some of the
clothing was modern and like some of
them like way they talked about the
technology the thinking yeah right so
that kind of stuff was kind of like so
it was kind of an interesting
juxtaposition that was kind of the vibe
I got right and like you said yeah what
do you think of it um it wasn't bad
actually it was funny because when I saw
the tricular I thought well it looks
kind of like silly it was like it was
like but it was a bit grittier a little
bit darker than I was expecting
um you know it's not a fantastic movie
but it actually it's not boring you know
it kind of had the long and a good clip
it was good pretty well paced yeah I
have to say that you know I think the
best thing about the movie is that the
acting was good all the performances
were solid there wasn't any dud actors
in it I liked Friar Tuck the best yeah
it also had a very tight edit other than
that the movie was an allegory for you
know cuz they they put a lot of modern
thinking in it but the story is really
about an allegory about a British
soldier who goes off
or while he was out his government
screwed him over and took his land so
later on he hooks up with an Isis
fighter and they find corruption in the
government and they form an Tifa to try
to overthrow it you see the the riot
shields the hoods with the what red
masks and everything but we know the
world doesn't work that way you
overthrow one government next thing you
know you have 20 fighting factions to
fill the power vacuum so there was a lot
of messaging in here that has nothing to
do really with the original version of
Robin Hood in fact calling this Robin
Hood is kind of a problem and in a way
because it it puts certain expectations
in the viewer you know I mean of what
what he's getting ready to see that's
not what you're gonna see here it kind
of struck me as a prequel to the more
familiar Robin Hood story because like
at the end of it that's right he's kind
of leading them all into Sherwood Forest
and some were like what happened before
that you're right it was kind of like a
prequel to yeah and you're not dealing
you're not dealing with the first you're
not dealing with the Sheriff of
Nottingham that you know right you don't
see that one until the end of the movie
other than that kind of a vapid shallow
[ __ ] really trying to be more than
what it really was though it was it was
alright yeah
crap I got a scrap
you
okay it's Jenny and I were back at AMC
just got done seen one called the green
book right green book and it was a story
about this guy named Don dr. Don Shurley
and he's this master pianist genius and
he's got to do this he's a black guy and
he's got to do this tour through the
segregated south back in in 1962 so he
hires this local love as bouncer from
the Copacabana yeah he's quite cool but
idea man so he takes him through on this
tour through the segregated south as
well as crazy-ass Jim Crow laws and kind
of access his bodyguard and it's kind of
a tale of an adventure what I really
like about this one I really love this
movie this is an excellent excellent
excellent movie this is this is gonna be
a group one of the good ones of the
month I can tell you it's a story of
life the Odd Couple
here watch the whole series of Odd
Couple you got it's real kind of like
cultured super sophisticated guy who's
kind of an ambiguous sexuality and he's
trying to get along with this just like
total working-class it's how you brought
the Dean of the Bronx and it is
hilarious yeah I think the like the
relationship between the two of them
which is like the hardness we this is
based on a true story yes true story
but the relationship between the two
guys it's just it's really what makes
this movie yet it's just their
relationship is just so yeah it's just
delightful it's just yeah and you
totally buy it
you totally I like this developing
friendship and feels like they're
completely different types but and it's
kind of it's almost kind of like a road
movie buddy movie - yeah
you know it's I really relate and then
actually the the theater was yeah yeah
and everybody loved it it's a I call it
a feel-good movie with some suspense and
some adventure they're going through the
Old South and I was born in 69 and you
know I can remember car these cars the
cars that they were shown growing up as
a little kid I remember those cars and I
remember a lot of those when locations
looked that way of course this version
of the south is gone
but I can remember it MTV changed it
forever
after MTV they that that was the end of
that south yeah so 1962 is very very old
southward yeah and it's funny because
well not funny but I mean because he's
so sophisticated so you get all these
albums and everything like that and so
he goes anyplace for like all these
really wealthy people
yeah then like they won't even like it
won't let him eat there yeah you can't
stay in the same hotel as his driver and
like he's a real oddball you know he's
got a throne in his office and he lives
in these exclusive places and he he
can't really fit in with the white
people of the time he can't fit in with
a black people either he's like his own
DZ's own being yes so I think that's
kind of what makes the friendship
between the two guys work because you
know Viggo Mortensen's character Toby
lip yeah Tony Liv Tony all tank guys Han
Tony yeah it looked like honestly when I
was looking at the end credits it looked
like the Tony Valley was his valley was
the name that he had and that he wanted
him it looks like someone with that same
last name wrote the script so I'm
assuming it
brought our his grandson perhaps
actually wrote this book because like I
said it's based on true story they
actually showed you know photos of the
real people like at them and kind of
said what happened in that man stuff
both of them passed away in 2013 yeah
and at the end the movie they show they
show you pictures of who they really
look like they after this evidently
after this little tour happened they
remained friends for life and when you
see the actual picture of dr. shirlee
you go yeah they got a spot on that's
exactly you know when I first saw Isis
man there's nobody like that existed two
big dashikis and all this sitting on a
throne no he wouldn't know they they
showed yeah he had like all these powers
he was like fabulously wealthy yeah you
know he was such a virtuoso pianist yes
possibly trained actually but yeah then
he kind of went in a little more of a
pop sort of direction but yeah yeah we
can't spoil all of it though just yeah
just a very recommend recommend a movie
it's a great yeah it's it's so funny
yeah it's really fun Alerus like I said
it's like a really feel-good movie and
like the just all the interactions and
conversations the two guys there's
justice yeah and this adventure that
they go on yeah yeah it's a truth
alright really good recommended yeah
okay we're back at AMC and Jen and I
just got done seeing Ralph breaks the
internet wreck-it Ralph
- yeah regular out - okay I actually did
not see the first one no I mean either
but I but you know like I said I don't
think you know it's a good standalone
you know I didn't see the first one of
them I was like whatever yeah the
premise premise of the story is very
long pretty much along the lines of tron
slightly rebooted you have a tease
videogame characters who would be you
know programs inside of 80s video games
in an arcade and because one of the
machine breaks they have to go to the
into the Internet to buy a students if I
had the park for sugar rush bra game
Penelope is the little girl the main
character she's one of the racers and
they are aware of an outside world but
they've never been to the Internet
itself and they get there and have this
big adventure there's a bunch of little
morality tales and much little values
there they make fun of Disney characters
Disney tropes quite a bit it is it's
very self satirize experience that was
very funny very out of character for
Disney Corporation
I would say where where the Nutcracker
failed I would say this movie succeeded
yeah seems like Disney's losing the
ability to tell a a traditional story
but there this was pretty good this one
was a contemporary story you know a lot
of little Easter eggs that ex Jenner's
would know what it is that they're
talking about this was good I'd say it's
up there with dr. Seuss different but
yeah as good as good as the Grinch is
one had like a sense of humor about
itself like I said I particularly liked
all the Disney Princesses Disney
Princesses that was very very funny like
yeah like all been there all in the room
with the little yeah
a little vanilla P character and they
were talking about starting to sing and
she's like yeah you have to know the
Disney Corporation and Disney I'll you
know and know how they handle Disney
Princesses and the culture around that
company to get it you know it was pretty
good in fact one of the characters in
this film as soon as we saw the
character we think it's somebody we know
who works for Disney who this may have
been based around it's hard to tell it
that looked a lot like a friend of our
friend of our friend that works at
Disney here we go that's crystal yeah I
thought they based the character for it
looks almost exactly it almost sounds
like event like the hair the way she
acted that I was like somebody is
somebody their destiny or knows crystal
she's very well known in Disney yeah she
yeah she plays a lot of characters plays
a lot of characters there but yeah if
you have kids you want to see this one
this one won't drive you crazy it's a
good story okay really nice animation
it's got like it's a really sweet story
the middle of it like wreck-it Ralph and
their Penelope there a little friendship
yes and you know like I said animation
is really nice and there's like a lot of
really funny stuff that it also get like
it's a lot of like dark web jokes and
you know like when they go inside the
internet like all the little pop-ups and
all this other guy yeah Randy Housewives
want to meet you really yeah yeah
youtube and youtubers yeah so it's like
it does never read the comments that
kind of says it was like it's very funny
it's like a you know like almost like a
satire type of Robbie but yeah I thought
it was really cute it's funny because
you kind of thought you were yeah I
think I was gonna like it but once it
started that's not five minutes into is
go Cassie was good it was pretty good
yeah was a key
[Music]